Hello !
Now that we're online,
we know that a lot of you
have been turning your
cameras...off.
And we get it.
You're online. You don't even
have to change out of your hoodie,
and your jogging bottoms and your pyjamas.
Wait my camera's on?!
BUT, let me give you a
couple of reasons why
you really need to
keep your cameras on
during your English
lessons withus on Zoom.
You ready?
Number 1: help to avoid the
English lesson from a horror story.
Okay let me just paint
a picture for you.
Imagine for one second, you
are your English teacher.
Good morning everybody!
How are you doing today?
Okay, well,
I know it's early.
I'mgoing to need you all to make
an effort to practise your speaking.
Sophia, howdid you find
this week's homework?
Can you imagine presenting a
project underthose circumstances?
Our teacher here is in a little
bit of a difficult situation.
It's really difficult to teach
to muted, black, squares.
It's also very importantthat you can see your classmates faces,
so that you can connect and feel like you'rein a real classroom.
Having your camera on will make you feel a
lot more confident when speakingEnglish.
So turn those cameras on!
Number 2: help yourself
with pronunciation.
Let's just goback to our English
teacher for one second.
Okay Sophia.
Could you repeat afterme please?
I can see 13 sheep through the window.
Let's try the wordsheep again.
Really elongate those "e's".
"eeeeeee"
"ee"
"sheeeeep"
"eee?"
Our teachers can really help
you with yourpronunciation,
if they can see you.
Non-verbal communication.
We use it every single day.
Iffacial expressions and body language
make up 70% of communication
when we're offline.
Wedefinitely need to be using
them when we're online.
So turn those cameras on!
Number 3: stopstrangers from
Zoom bombing your classroom.
Okay, this might sound obvious,
but this person
is a lot easier to spot than this person.
Yes, at the British Council we do everything
to ensure only you and your classmates
are allowed into your classroom.
But you can neverbe too careful.
We want you to be safe whilst
learning English with us.
Your parents want youto be safe
whilst learning English with us.
I'm assuming you want you to be safe
whilst learningEnglish with us.
Help us detect strangers
trying to enter your classroom
by turning yourcameras on.
Okay, I hope I've made my point.
Please, please, please, please, please, please,
turnyour cameras on!
What?
Turn those cameras ON.
You'll have a lot more fun,
your teachers will have a
lot more fun
and just generally it will be a much more enjoyable
experience for everybody involved.
Okay that's everything from me.
For today.
Bye!